I've had the story for three years I've
had this interview with Virginia Roberts
we would not put it on the air the
palace found out that we had her whole
allegations about Prince Andrew and
threatened us a million different ways
we convinced her to talk to us
it was unbelievable what we had Clinton
we had everything I for three years to
get it on to no avail and now it's all
coming out and it's like these new
relevation Brad Edwards the Attorney
three years ago saying like aunt like we
there will come a day where we will
realize Jeffrey Epstein was the most
prolific pedophile this country has ever
known so many of you have probably seen
that clip the full clip of course you
can go to project very to us that's
someone amy robach I believe from Good
Morning America ABC News and I want to
if you haven't seen that go watch the
full clip but I want to show a more
recent clip with our guest will be on a
second when they ask for a response from
producers here you go MA mr. gholson I'm
a reporter with project Veritas we have
footage of a amy robach saying that ABC
news executives killed her Jeffrey
Epstein story some years ago do you have
a comment sir I done I done do you have
comment I do not have a I'm gonna play
the footage for you sir I've had the
story of three years I've had this
interview with Virginia Roberts we would
not put it on the air first of all I was
told who's Jeffrey Epstein no one knows
who that is that seems you were about to
be summoned as soon as we per
wouldn't be able to interview well she
said her Jeffrey Epstein story was uh
killed some years ago said that she had
the story but ABC News executives told
her they squashed it so if you have a
comment sir now would be a good time
[Music]
okay so here to tuck book I should
mention we were taping a trump sketch
not long ago weren't planning on doing
this interview today but our guests made
some time of course please support them
at Project Veritas you can go watch more
content
mister James O'Keefe thank you for
taking the time sir thank you for having
me on today thank you I apologize for
the raccoon eyes here I know I look like
a crazy person this was not this wasn't
on the schedule as it were before we get
into this the whole epstein scandal
because this is the number one story
everywhere we're just talking about this
off air explain provide a little bit of
context for maybe some people who don't
know who amy robach is and why this is
so significant because it is it is mind
blowing but I don't want to misrepresent
anything and get anyone into legal hot
water as I have a tendency to do well
and if I look down I have the transcript
of Amy's remarks because I'm fond of
saying Stephen that the tape speaks for
itself and in this case this is pretty I
think it's pretty mind-blowing because
she's so honest I think she comes across
so well on this tape I you know I don't
think we're exposing Amy here I think
we're just this is a hot mic moment this
is well how these people really feel and
behave and think and you kind of really
see the anger and the frustration in her
voice because I mean put yourself in her
shoes she's flying these victims across
the country this is three years ago
mm-hmm and the executives squashed the
story she says they spiked the story and
she's so upset because she had the story
so she says and I'm gonna read some of
these quotes here she says it's
unbelievable what we had on Clinton we
had everything she says I think he was
killed a hundred percent she's talking
about Jeff Epstein and then that's why I
really believe it like I really believe
it so the context is she's an anchor for
Good Morning America we have an Insider
and I'll give you some information that
maybe I haven't given anybody else we
have multiple insiders oh inside of ABC
News who are I think that frustrated is
an understand they're pissed at
management there
angry at ABC News executives you saw us
chasing down the president of ABC News
in a street after we did that Stephen
that was late last week executive
reached out to me directly
ABC News gave us a comment that comment
appears to be written by lawyers
it's very milquetoast you know yeah the
exact opposite of what amy is saying in
this tape this lawyer Lee statements so
a lot of things happening and what's
remarkable is that the left loves this
story
Acacio Cortez tweeted it it's like
number one story on BBC News yeah the
palace in England is putting pressure on
ABC so a lot of things to talk about
here yeah I think you know when I first
heard about what you were going to leak
I thought this was going to be a leak to
tape you know of like Jeff Epstein
saying like oh hey Hillary haha you know
he's clearly was murdered so at first I
was like ah this is disappointing and
then when I watched the whole thing I
thought wow this is about the arguably
biggest or one of the biggest news
networks in the world punting
systematically punting a story that
absolutely considering what they covered
with far less evidence with Kavanagh
with Smollett right they had no interest
in covering whatsoever and like you said
I don't think this is exposing Amy she
was frustrated because these were orders
coming from the top down and her
mentioning Clinton specifically wanted
my research and I thought what this is
this is about as as damning as it gets
yeah if you had substituted the word
Clinton for Trump we had everything we
had these women it would be universally
condemned even by the right right and
you point out it's about cavanaugh it's
about there's this I can't remember the
accuser who accused Trump of something
in the last week and the allegations are
aired there are credible allegations so
right this is yeah I mean I haven't seen
one liberal I got a guy from progress
now Colorado saying I hate Oh Keith but
this is great reporting so it's one of
those things where the president of ABC
News sent someone to our office and gave
us a very serious comment we have these
insider Stephen who reach out to us now
these people do not reach out to the New
York Times The Washington Post CBS News
they don't trust those people they're so
angry and are they still inside
ABC News by the yes they're still
multiple okay apparently there's
paranoia happening inside ABC News today
they're looking for the leisure I wonder
why but they're spending so much time
trying to find the person or persons who
leaked this rather than actually address
the substance of the thing so the good
news for us is that as long as they have
that mentality where they're going to
try to continue to squash cover-up not
actually reform their lack of
journalistic behaviors there will always
be more information coming out in the
future and I think you'll see another
tape from these insiders leaking to us
every now and then we have quote-unquote
insiders reach out to us and we say well
you know what we just we do a late night
show we just had a crack-addicted puppet
so you should probably go to James
O'Keefe and project very done those are
the guys you want to talk with about
this but I'm very serious about this I
go across the United States and I want
to give you guys a compliment because I
go I speak to Texas A&M and these places
and everyone comes up and says I I watch
Crowder is is my main I'm serious my
main source of news these are kids
they're eighteen to twenty-two they say
Ben Shapiro Steve Crowder and of course
Instagram Twitter you know and a lot of
people are watching this right now a lot
of kids a lot of people working for
Google or what have you come to us we
will work with you it's fully legal if
you're on the inside if you're a person
who just wants to be a journalist you
Steven a lot of people are saying well
I'm really upset that James O'Keefe
broke this story and not my favorite New
York Times reporter right and I'm saying
well there's a reason for that because
people don't feel comfortable going to
the New York Times so go to Project
Veritas calm slash brave and submit your
thing to us and we'll work with you and
I want to talk about this for a second
journalism because we hear it off
obviously tossed around from the left a
first day going to fake news and then
Donald Trump jujitsu tit and they accuse
them of fake news and conservatives
often say well there is no journalism on
the left but here's something that's
important here yeah we can just point to
the hypocrisy right of the Cavanaugh
huger's the Covington Catholic school
students a specialist Jesse Smollett it
was ABC News they ran the exclusive
interview where Jesse small explained
that he was the victim of a hate crime
and they handled it with a straight face
so that's very important we can point
out the double standard but here's
something else when you're talking about
this is this is from years ago this
information you know people who tend to
run pedophile rings they don't operate
alone
who knows if this story would have been
run while Jeffrey Epstein was alive or
while this information would have been
maybe less of a cold trail if it could
have stopped any other active pedophile
who might have been involved that is
important that is what we're gonna talk
about Erin Brockovich with some tap
water how about an actual pedophile
island and journalists out there taking
an interest
taking a vested interest in the American
public making sure that these predators
are fingered out in the public I mean
let me quote amy robach from this hot
mic Good Morning America tape of her she
says quote Jeff Epstein made his whole
living blackmailing people yep there are
a lot of men on those planes a lot of
men who visited that Island a lot of
powerful men and and and you know it's
interesting is that she would never say
these things on the air because the
network executives and and there's the
tape is still there they have these
tapes why don't they just air them right
um you know you make a good point it's a
cover-up it may be a criminal issue the
FBI some people have said the FBI should
be involved with James Goldston
president of ABC News what did they know
and when did they know it and who are
these people that contacted them listen
it's a big story and you have to
remember that the media is complicit in
all of this the media has more power
than the government here and that's why
we think this is an Epstein cover-up the
media is the story Steven and there's
more you know more insiders are coming
to us today but we had a new insider
with an ABC News contact us and leaked
us memorandums in the network well then
we should probably put a moratorium on
the word paranoid for you let NBC
they're just concerned about what's
actually happening why don't they just
reform the actual be people always say
James aren't you worried someone's going
to infiltrate Project Veritas and I said
I have to behave like there are six
jurors on this shoulder and six jurors
on this shoulder at all times I have to
behave with such a degree of ethics and
integrity that I'm not paranoid this is
the world we live in if you're worried
about your expectation of privacy guess
what you have no privacy right you can
just take out your phone and hit a
button these days but instead of
reforming the behaviors that they seem
to be covering up the behavior but I
think this one's different I think we've
reached a critical mass on this one
where there's a movement
Insider is now coming out of the
woodwork Steven yes and I think that a
lot of you will take this just as
license to go on about Jeffrey Epstein's
death which I don't think is
conspiratorial at this point to say that
we certainly don't have all of the
answers largely because we don't have
all the answers and I don't mean that as
a Jesse Ventura well I'm just asking
questions like where we literally don't
have the tape and there are medical
examiner's who said well is more in line
with some kind of a homicide than a
suicide I haven't had time again hence
the crazy makeup and hair I apologize to
people out there so I have enough time
to do the research but I'm willing to
bet my bottom dollar that they probably
have run some specials on these nightly
shows there at ABC about sex trafficking
and sex rings I've seen them all the
time it could it could happen to you
it's closer than you think and they run
this out there to virtue signal
meanwhile they have information on
arguably the most prolific sexual
predator that we've known in the United
States and tied to very very powerful
people this is why this is so important
because when we talk about me to write
at one point that was when we had cabin
on ice at Hawn there does need to be due
process with me too we can't just go out
there a torch and pitchfork mob there I
there premise was these are powerful men
people in power so they need to be
questioned it seems that that doesn't
apply to some of the most powerful men
on the face of the earth as long as
they're on the right political side
because I can't think of a story beyond
someone who has ties with global leaders
former presidents who was running a
pedophile ring this is not alleged we
know that this was a man who engaged in
pedophilia and actually had an ring an
organization that was running pedophilia
for other people actively I can't
imagine a story that would be more
important for journalists I mean what is
what's required to get a Pulitzer right
I mean she says it I'm gonna read this
quote Virginia Roberts that's the the
woman accused using Epstein she told me
everything says amy robach of ABC's Good
Morning America quote she had pictures
she had everything she was in hiding we
convinced her to come out we convinced
her to talk to us so they did their jobs
as journalists and that's why she's so
upset I mean imagine if you spent months
of your time you know great journalism
convincing these people to have the
bravery to go on camera to sit and
she talks and then ABC spikes the story
and hanison III have people working for
me who worked in the television industry
now and it's pretty extraordinary have
to go back to Jeffrey Wigand the 60
Minutes guy in the 90s that they were
putting pressure on CBS from the tobacco
industry it's a pretty extraordinary
thing and I think your point is there
has to be the same standard if you want
to air allegations uncorroborated from
about Kavanaugh and about Trump but
you're not going to run those
allegations against Jeffrey Epstein why
is that yeah and I think an important
differentiation by the way we just had
another story yesterday people can
search us I don't have overlays today
again wasn't planning on this interview
but another lady came out and said that
she actually she created a story
regarding Kavanagh it's tough to keep
track because there were so many who
came out of the woodwork after Kavanagh
became a Supreme Court justice the
stories went away whereas after the
death of Epstein more and more
information is coming to light they're
not going away it only gets worse I
think people need to understand this is
not a right or left issue that's a stark
and frightening contrast and it's
infuriating to people who are working in
the media whether it's the CNN insiders
who gave us those audio tapes you saw
last month
that's the Jeff Zucker phone calls
whether it's these people inside ABC
News I can't give you any information
about who they are because I'd give them
up but they said to me James this was so
infuriating to us to know this so in
other words you have very good people
working in media you don't have bad
people they're not necessarily even
liberal people or right-wing they're
just they're just people working for
this this crappy I would say corrupt
organ of propaganda that manufactures
the public's consent and I think you're
seeing I'm very serious about this I
think we're reaching a tipping point in
this country if we haven't reached it
yet we're almost there where they can
maybe stop they can plug this hole they
can they can left Alec what's that
alligator game where you're banging all
the alligators it's like whack-a-mole
but another one you're thinking of they
also have a lack although we got to
cover up this leak but then there's an
army of a hundred insiders within CBS
ABC CNN New York Times they're disgusted
by how corrupted
is Project Veritas dot-com / brave we
will protect you I will have your back
no matter what and I'm very I'm very
encouraged to see that these Patriots
who are not conservative there are just
people who are upset about what's going
on and I think there's gonna be more to
come
well I think particularly the epstein
suicide story like you mentioned aoc
tweeted out obviously some of some of
this information these videos but the
epstein suicide story seems to have
really United both the right yes and the
left here that's pretty remarkable so
yeah it seems to me this could be that
sort of watershed moment right let me
ask do you have any do you have any idea
as to who specifically or do you know
who specifically tried to pressure robot
to punt the story I mean there's a very
few people in ABC News I mean the most
powerful people in ABC News you're
looking at the executive producer of
Good Morning America and the president
of ABC News that that person's these
names you can find them they're public
information Chris blasto is the former
executive producer and the president of
ABC News his name is James Goltz and I
will say Steven Chris blasto is very he
cooperated with me he came he talked to
me he came to my office we had some
off-the-record conversations but he got
a comment and I would say it was the
president of ABC News James Goldston
it's not like Disney the board of
directors at Disney got involved in
editorial decisions maybe not but
definitely James Goldston is the
individual you should you can tweet at
him I've been talking to him all day
I've been we confronted him on the
street I would love to have been a fly
on the wall in the room with James
Goldston when he was talking to his
various friends powerful buddies who as
Amy says were on those airplanes alan
dershowitz is another name stephen that
was mentioned he's actually a pretty
libertarian guy right this politics
notwithstanding I would suspect that
somehow maybe he was implicated in this
I don't know it's Amy's Amy saying these
things on the hot mic right and she came
out with a statement afterwards sent
trying to say this isn't really as big
of a deal as it's being made out to be
no one ever told me not to run the story
it seems very much like a boiler
plate response I think it was probably
written by somebody else a $50,000 per
word statement by amy robach there but
the comment alan dershowitz with some
sticky notes here yeah
quote this is amy robach statement today
quote in the years since no one has ever
told me or the team to stop reporting on
Jeffrey Epstein it was literally the
opposite of what she says well in this
tape right I mean come on I mean this is
so obviously written by lawyers that
it's not even worth really taking
seriously
well here's the thing to me too as we
look at this because I don't want I
don't want to get into the Epstein you
know sort of conspiracies regarding the
suicide I don't I don't I don't think he
killed himself that's just mad I don't
have any answers but that's just this is
my opinion it's not well James is here
to talk about but considering that this
information was withheld for so long and
like we said it could have potentially
saved people from victimization yeah
would it be unrealistic to think that
there's probably more information
regarding the Epstein case could even be
just people who visited the island or
the apartment great that is a great
point you know think about conspiracies
by the way they call me a conspiracy
theorist I don't and this is I don't
publish journalism less you can see the
person's lips moving I don't write
manufacture quotes I don't print hearsay
this is what journals do I don't do that
right I only publish information if you
can see their face and watch their lips
making the comments but you making a
very astute observation this tape did
exist of amy robach at Good Morning
America it was on their server or
wherever and Anna's and a source leaked
it to us there are other tapes there are
there is other iPhone recordings audio
and video of conversations with these
quote-unquote powerful people on these
quote-unquote
airplanes traveling to and fro and I bet
you there is someone watching this right
now who has access to that going oh my
god should I give this to Project
Veritas or is it gonna blow me and I
will say to you that you can send us a
private encrypted message there's a
thing called encryption on protonmail or
signal we will protect you and I will
take the arrows I will not give you up
and I think it's very important that
other people come out that's what I'm
talking about the watershed moment that
that there that there are people out
there in fury
they're indignant and they want people
to see it so I think that's a very
astute observation it really has come
down to what else do we not know if we
know that this was withheld and it could
have been withheld in a period of years
again where it could have stopped
additional sex trafficking for all we
know we don't have to say everything
have to hedge it with for all we know
because we don't know a whole lot but
when you contrast this with remember
obviously the Donald Trump tape did the
grad met that was a big deal right
remember for a long time they said we
also have tapes of him using the n-word
on the set of The Apprentice a big thing
him using racial slurs I mean if this
lives on right at ABC for a long time
this is still in their video logs this
is an off mic moment if those other
tapes exist that's exactly right now and
Trump yeah you don't think for a second
that they would be releasing those yeah
I think them I think the I think nature
abhors a vacuum and I think what's going
to happen is that I don't know I don't
call them the free market but there's
this effect where this tape was leaked
to somebody but the thing Stephan is
that no they have no place to go these
sources cannot go to the New York Times
they don't trust them right so there has
to be an outlet where people can come to
it's project Veritas calm slash brave I
keep pitching it to you because in the
last 24 hours
we have had six new people within news
networks reach out to me so your point
is very well made they're there they've
got the access they're just afraid you
know I think a lot of people go through
life wanting to eliminate risk they they
they're worried about the secondary
effects of publishing information
they're gonna they're coming after their
children or what-have-you but I think
that people are so angry right now that
they're putting their love for citizens
having the public right to know what is
going on above their own concern about
their own safety that is what is
happening right now in this country and
I think it's a great thing to behold I
think when you see these stories go
viral yeah I think there are two three
lines here yeah I think people I think
there's risk aversion but I also think
it's about accountability because
they're not averse they're not averse to
taking risks as far as you see how many
whistleblowers come forward anonymous
whistleblowers whether it's Russia
whether it's you know Russian collusion
whether it's impeachment right they can
go they know they have plenty places ago
they can go to the New York Times
go to NBC ABC CBS CNN MSNBC because they
will be protected and this will be run
as a completely legitimate story even if
it's not video graphic evidence even if
it's not proof even if it's hearsay
these whistleblowers they're they're
lauded as heroes for these stories for
which we have no evidence but in this
case it's that they're risk-averse
because there's accountability but in a
negative way there's accountability if
they run a story that can hurt the DNC
establishment and by proxy traditional
media they're not afraid of leaking
they're just afraid of leaking these
kinds of stories and that's what is so
frustrating and sickening it's the
double standards and it's and the left
is starting to see it they talk about
democracy dies in darkness and the truth
is more important than ever but in
reality a lot of people that work for
these companies are angry at their
management amy robach is a very good
journalist she's a very serious
anchorwoman and she did all this
reporting and that's what we hear we
heard it in the CNN tapes people are
angry they're infuriated they're
righteously indignant to borrow Andrew
Breitbart book title and they're coming
out yes oh I think there's a new breed
of heroes in this country in this world
of illusion and quasi illusion there's
the honest cop be honest school teacher
the honest you know satellite upload
technician for CNN and they are the new
whistleblowers the citizen
whistleblowers it's not like this 30
year old leaker in the in the government
with the Ukraine here say or Bob
Woodward's anonymous sources who are
quoting other people these are people
who are risking their whole risking
their careers these people will never
work in media again right if they're
found out but they believe in something
greater than themselves and I believe
that we are at the dawn of a new era and
I know that you have a million millions
of people watch this is a very very
serious broadcast because you have so
many people in this country watching
right now and they're going you know
what should I send my iPhone recording
to James O'Keefe do I want to risk it
and I will tell you that you should
project Merritt hasta Kampf slash brave
or Veritas tips at protonmail comm and
we will protect you I will have your
back I've never lost a lawsuit Steven
that I've been sued 20 times I've never
I've never lost
we're gonna fight them all the way to
the end yes sorry are you hearing my dog
growl here hoppers here because as well
again he's usually not in the studio we
have guests this is just kind of tossed
together here at the last minute no I
also think if people are looking to go
into journalism listen they need a look
at what we're talking about here they
need to look at what's happening online
they need a look at even people like
like and II know with with anta that was
another story that wasn't covered and
then you go look at you know understand
the context understand sort of the
subtext with Amy here when she's talking
out of frustration she is not a villain
but it does show you that if you want to
go into journalism because you want
until the stories that matter listen
right now James can speak completely
freely you can speak completely freely I
can speak completely freely if you work
in a traditional media outlet you cannot
plan to do honest journalism
it is forbidden it's not allowed and I
think people need to understand that now
that these same people who want the
gatekeepers big tech to cover which
stories are legitimate which stories are
fake news online they want that curated
they also I think I don't remember it
was some conservative nevertrump er who
was saying we need that with media it's
important because now everyone can get
their media out there we need these
gatekeepers well listen there you go
folks this is the kind of gatekeeping
that's always been the case by the way
in traditional media it's just yet now
people like you are able to showcase it
you cannot plan to do honest journalism
at a place like ABC or CNN if it's an
inconvenient story they won't allow it
what the content is king you know Disney
is trying to we're the number one
trending thing on Twitter you know today
and Disney was trying to like brought
you know do something and they're paid
advertising campaign trended less than
the Epstein video so content is king at
if you got video tape it's gonna get up
to but I think there's a symbiotic
relationship between those in power and
who they're reporting on
that's what even Noam Chomsky said that
right easiest relationship but it's also
we go there like we actually like and II
know and and amy robach actually fly to
the location interview the witnesses
take out their camera I mean so much a
journalism now is like googling and
tweeting right and you got to stop
googling and tweeting and actually go do
the shoe leather thing you actually go
and you've done that you did it we did
it once with the aunt before anyone else
is doing an iPhone we went to antiphon
in Utah where they were handing your axe
picks and they were getting sawed-off
shotguns for a Ben Shapiro event claim
he was a Nazi we have the footage of
them handing us a knife and an ice pick
and there was a guy there a kit member
his name the guy who had that panic
attack on here was a 60 Minutes or 20 20
he was there he saw us handing the
footage over to the police showing him
the footage going there that's the knife
there that's the stun gun which by the
way was later taken from the girl who
was arrested that a night person from I
believe it was ABC was either Dateline
or 60 minutes or 2028 a member exactly
he said I'm not interested hey Lawson we
have this story said no no I'm not
interested we gave it to all the local
news there in Utah they said no no we're
not interested and I will tell you this
I've always known about bias from an
entertainment standpoint in the
entertainment industry but that was the
first time we had accidentally stumbled
across journalism and it was remarkable
that not 80 90 100 percent of
journalists in the area covering that
event had no interest in video graphic
evidence of someone committing a felony
which by the way led to their arrest
none of them so I can only imagine the
kind of life that you live James you
must have to have to sleep with no not
one eye open both can you do the sleep
where you the with both eyes oh no now I
need eight hours a night of sleep but I
think the way they threatened you now is
through litigation that's how they
really try to get to us they failed they
we haven't lost a lawsuit in two years
but I commend you for going there I
think what's vice used to have a Time
Square advertisement this is vice media
and they're selling Amato as we go there
imagine how broken the media must be
when your unique value proposition is to
actually go to the location you're
reporting on you just mentioned
something about Disney's advertised
promoted story on Twitter yes are you
guys live action is not allowed to
promote at all on Twitter yeah we're not
allowed I'm not allowed to promote at
all because the campaign's that Twitter
created themselves was then deemed a
violation of Twitter's advertising
campaign can project very Tufts
advertisement Twitter you guys allow no
I'm not even verified I don't have a
very tosses unverified 650,000 followers
may be less than you but I'm not
verified I think by the way not being
verified and having that many followers
and doing this too that's the new
verified right right yeah right I have I
have thanks for the insults there I
appreciate
no no no we've got a number one trend
Epstein cover up and then number two
Disney Disney Plus so yeah the mean this
isn't I want to take everyone's so
cynical out there they're so upset about
how bad things are in social media but
think about it for a minute they hate me
they shadow band so forth and so on the
story is the number one trend right and
Disney and you want to talk about
messing with powerful people Disney's
right brand advertising campaign is not
even as high of a trend as our YouTube
video today right so my point to you is
that the story is good enough yeah if
the content is strong enough and if you
have and I'm gonna say something you
know but I'm gonna say it because I'm
very passionate if you got the bastards
dead to rights
you will be the number one trending
thing on Twitter even today in Silicon
Valley so the trick is Steve we got we
got to get the content we got to have
the insiders come to us that is
absolutely true
however I will say this because you're
this broke through right today and it
was number one trend but if you add it
up cumulatively right
Disney they can run ads and ABC and NBC
they can run ads yes we can't run ads
and you can't run ads and live action
can't run outs you do have to wonder how
many stories would be at the top of
trending if not being buried for the
page friends and that's important
because when they say they're banning
all political ads right well no one on
the right no one on the left can ban
political ads okay what about Disney
what about ABC what about NBC yes by the
way you talk about our Disney paid trend
this story of yours ABC it's a Disney
owned parent company if I'm not mistaken
I don't want to be conspiratorial but
the fact that they bought out the top
Trender attempted to while this was
coming out like that's important people
need to understand it's not just about
politicians buying ads but giant media
entities because they will do everything
they can to size but you do what you
just said Disney buying out the trend
today that in in conspiracies there are
people involved in it that I don't know
let's say there's seventeen people like
the assistant that works for the
assistant general counsel at Disney goes
well that's corrupt right that's corrupt
and he goes you know what I'm gonna take
a screenshot of all these secret
documents about buying trends because of
the apps teen video and I'm gonna send
that to Project Veritas yeah that's how
we change the world that's a that's a
chain of events project I keep pitching
this in oh I want you to
project Veritas comm / brave if you're
the assistant that works in the General
Counsel's office for Disney and you're
buying the trend today that that's
underneath our trend to try to black it
out again I'm assuming that's what's
happening then send us the secret
document whether that's what's happening
or not it still is an unfair playing
field for Jack to say well we're just
gonna ban political ads but then ban
individual conservatives from running
ads we talked about this yesterday live
action do you know they can't run ads on
Twitter unless they remove all
ultrasound pictures from their website
not on Twitter so if they do that but
allow major news entities or or
multi media entities like 8 what is it
Disney Disney of course owns ABC
yes and you have Viacom and of course
we've run up against NBC Comcast Vox I
mean it really is it doesn't it doesn't
require a conspiracy with so many people
to be in on it for me my litmus test for
conspiracy is like if you look at area
51 you go well how many underlings have
to be in on that who never broke their
silence yeah something like this it's
Jack Dorsey in a room with four people
that's really all that's required it
doesn't need to be some kind of an
equity it could be three people or four
people but I think the thing about
investigating the paragon of
investigative journalism is we we have
to act as what's been called the
custodians of conscience we test and
affirm what is in what is not an affront
to people we shake them away right and
amy robach is not she's not a right
laner no but she was sitting there and
her conscience her conscience said to
herself you know what this is wrong and
even that in that agreement with those
four or five people one of those people
is their conscience is gonna get the
best of them and they're gonna go this
is wrong and I and I just believe that
we're at a time in history right now
where them we cause of social media
because of the digital ability to get
things out instantaneously to a million
people in a New York minute I think
there's gonna be a movement of these
heroic people that put that put
knowledge of what is going on above
their own sacrifice people always say to
me do I fear for my life I do not I do
not think about that I take precautions
of which I will not get into sure
publicly
but now I don't fear for my life I
because I'm so passionate you know we
are so passionate about informing people
we actually get a kick out of it we
enjoy doing these stories and I think
there's a lot of people out there who go
through life they they go through having
the comforts of life and you know
protecting their own sense of security
but I think that's changing right now I
really do and I think that people out
there are willing to come public with
more information and I think it's an
important point you make that obviously
this is why we've always championed sort
of back when it was new media now it's
just media but that's also why you're
seeing big tech the most powerful
companies in the history of the world
and I mean that I mean in the history of
the world as far as controlling what
information is delivered right now they
keep trying to change the rules because
like you said you can blast it out in a
New York minute
you used to be able to you can today
mostly but you still have to cut through
a lot of fog you know that it's an
uphill battle same thing with us they
want to change that playing field let me
ask you this final question do you think
there's more information to come out
here with Epstein that we don't have
access to yet if you have to bet I'm a
hundred percent high I'm a hundred be on
the record hundred percent okay I didn't
want to get your sources all these
sources are coming to me like as I'm
sitting here with you right here there
are sources pinging me and texting me
through veritas tips at protonmail comm
is how they come to us so yes the answer
is yes this is by order of magnitude the
biggest story I've ever seen us break in
terms of the virality of it I'm gonna
let it breathe for 24 hours and then
you'll hear from Project Veritas this
week yeah I think the Epstein sir not
only the biggest or that you've broken
obviously in relation to Epstein but I
think that the Epstein scandal could be
one of could be the biggest story as it
relates to the scandal of American media
yeah and the failure to do their job
that's that's well put that's well said
and I think you're gonna see more come
out yes what does it take guys what does
it take if not known pedophiles what
does it take for you to do your job you
guys let me know cuz if that isn't it
well then don't blame us when we don't
trust you alright that is James O'Keefe
it is Project Veritas comm slash brave
and please do go and watch all the
content of the clips in their entire
James and apply to be a journalist and
apply to work for us if you want to do
real reporting at project Veritas
dot-com / brave absolutely if you
enjoyed this video subscribe hit the
notification bell or do consider joining
mud club at ladder with CARICOM slash
mud club because this is how we do our
show in our journalism because we've
been demonetized for a whole long time
now and that's not coming back also I
know you're asking yourself was I
actually doing a Donald Trump sketch or
did I just did I merely fall asleep on a
sundial wearing my Ravens for the answer
to that tune in to the Thursday
livestream that's every Thursday at 8
p.m. Eastern we'll see you there